Protein.
Our lives are on the line
Ah.
OHHHH NO
[laughter]
We had a lot of fun filming our Odysseus challenge
So we thought we'd do another famous archery challenge
William Tell. if you don't know who William Tell is, he shot an apple off
of his son's head. legend goes at least what we're gonna do that today in real life. Our lives are on the line
Just kidding. Actually, they'll be really dumb to do it for real
So we're going to be using these, padded arrows and we will be wearing face masks,
It's still gonna hurt like crap if we get hit in the chest or the stomach or the middle of the face
Or the sack! yeah dude....
why was he shooting arrows off at his kids (??)
Good question
Dose anyone know the legend of William Tell?? time for some jank history guys?
I just remember, Betty shot and Apple office son said that's about it. Why?
Like, I can't move this. Apple has to be shot off of my head
[Laughing]
Like, how did it get here? I have no idea,
Well, I don't know every detail but, William Tell he was a total badass dude
Apparently this guy is like an ace shot with a crossbow. And he assassinated this like evil Duke, starts an open Civil War.
We are all gonna roll of dice
Everybody assigned a number, roll the dice for being the son someone just rolled the dice for being the father if you kill your son
You become the son on the next archery take
Wait! So we are gonna shoot arrows at ourselves?
Yeah. I want to shoot someone up wait, can you can you actually let me see let me see if I can do this.
wait this guy dude...
His arm is broken.
Adrian don't do it. There's no accuracy there. His collarbone is split in two places. Yeah, well
I feel, I feel fine.
This die roll is for the person who will be doing the shooting, this is for William Tell.
Five.
[Wren's dramatic gasp]
All right, Wren. Wren is going to be holding someone's life in his hands
Oh man.
LITTLE BILLIAM
ahahahaa
One
Thats Jake!!
JAKE
[evil wren laughter]
All right, Jake grab a helmet.
You don't want to kill your son.
If you're gonna miss, miss high.
Don't miss low.
What happens if Wren hits the Apple?
Yeah, what if he nails it, perfectly?
What so what's the prize? then you get to eat it. I flip chairs
[more laughter]
There's no way Wrens gonna make it.
All right, who here thinks Wren will make it?
[crickets]
(rip wren)
WOW!! Sorry Wren!
Wait a minute.
Do I have the arrow on backwards?
Good luck Jake!
Good luck Wren!
OH!
[Laughter]
You didn't even warn me, man you just went for it.
That was!- I said are we ready?
The new shooter is Jake.
I think Wren and I have a long history of
Doing crazy stuff and coming out alive.  The main thing is just not to hit him, directly in the face.
This is Terrifying!
Ready?
Lets go Wren!
Alright,
Three
Two
One
Wren! You moved!
He Flinched!
you gotta hold still
You cant flinch
You hit me right in the collar bone!
Are you trying to make me Adrian?
Two
Yes!
Yesssss
Yes, yeah. Jake I will miss high.
I don't think Clint's gonna do it
Everybody's been just like, assassinating the sons.
Nobody should aiming over high, everything's always been low.
I was close!
Shoot him right in the face!
I got you, son
He doesn't love you back
Son, this ones for you.
I believe in you Clinton
That's not how you're supposed to aim...
ah!
OHH!!
Oh Man!!
Woah!
Woosh!
Dude.
oof
That took a, that took a
There is, there is literally an arrow.
There's an arrow in my cheekbone, right here.
dude.
Niko, my turn.
Get out of here you ghost.
I've had pretty good luck with the archery challenges. Let's see if this changes here.
I love you pop!
Right in the nose!
Right in the FACE!!
The apple remains.
hehehe
All right, my turn.
OKAY.
This is not gonna
No one's actually gotten this yet
Eight inches higher then,
Im not quite sure...
Maybe, maybe Jarrett will be the true William Tell
YAY!
I didn't hurt anyone!
[Dramatic music by Carmichael]
Nope.
Okay, consistency!
I really wanna try dude, this looks like fun.
Wheres an arrow?
This guy's got a broken collarbone, he cant aim!
Uh-oh
Dude this thing is like- I like it on the other end,
hold on.
One more! one more!
Here, here.
Adrian should not be doing this.
Nicks up. Nick did pretty good last time. So
I feel, If anyone's gonna get it,
I mean, hes definitely a likely candidate, Are you going home to mama tonight?
Are you right eye dominant or left eye dominant?
Dude don't confuse him anymore.
Don't confuse him anymore!!
I'm just centered.
[laughter]
Tactical stance!
Tactical
TACTICAL!!!
Niko ducked again?!
Niko!!
What are you doing!?
Get him another arrow!
boy you better close your eyes or I'm gonna close them for you.
I see an arrow pointed right at my face.
I don't know
Come on, Nick. Here we go
OOOH
That was actually close.
that was honorably close. I didn't kill you though!
Carmichael needs to go!
give me that camera boy.
All right
Here we go!
You got this man!
OHH!!
[Laughter]
Bro right between the eyes
That was perfectly right between the eyes.
That was probably the most effective death, we've seen yet.
Bulls-eye!
Carmichael's the boy!
Carmichael 's the boy!
Im the BOY!
So archery is cool and all but hey, guess what, we just put out a new video on the Corridor Channel
It's about the world's longest lightsaber
that I somehow built and made a reality
And today we're gonna talk about some of the effects that made it happen.
With this...
[Loading Wren.png]
Totally lost my train of thought, I don't know where I was going with that
Why did you get a banana?
I don't-
For my protein
[this is why I blocked wren on instagram]
This whole video is about a lightsaber that just gets longer and longer but here's the thing
Traditionally lightsabers were like the hardest effect to do
Okay, they were not necessarily the hardest effect
But no one liked doing them because they were so like time intensive
but fortunately thanks to videocopilot.net
there is a Fantastic FREE plugin for After Effects to do this super easily,
and I'm gonna kind of break down the process for that.
So the plugin is called Saber. So what makes Sabre so nice and easy for lightsaber effects
Is that all of the settings are
Automated there's only two points that you gotta animate,
the base in the tip of the lightsaber
And so it helps if you have like a actual lightsaber to track but on a lot of these shots
We didn't even have that. We just kind of had to wing it.
There's literally dozens of presets that I can select.
Let's go to Kryptonite, what does kryptonite do? oh!
So if I had a kryptonite lightsaber, it would look like that. I think we used literally like the most defaults
I don't think we changed any settings,. I don't even think we changed the color of the lightsaber
That's the lightsaber look that we were going for and it is the default one you start with
So what's cool about this? You can adjust the glow. So if I set to like zero glow or like a million percent glow
[snickers]
[laughs]
[original_lightsaber_sound.wav]
The lightsaber itself is actually white, it's the glow that is colored
I can change the intensity of that glow to really be really, you know low
I can change the glow bias and globe spread
These are all settings that you can play around with when you're trying to dial in your effects and whatnot.
when doing a lightsaber shot, you want to have some sort of prop that you can track something with the base and a tip so you can actually track
the base and tip of the shot
Now what you can do is you can keyframe directly inside of the effect and you'll notice you see
How there's actually motion blur involved as well.  Before you used to have to shape it with the masks and whatnot
You don't have to do that anymore
So yeah
I just went through and frame-by-frame
animate the position for all that and that's where most of the work for this video came from is just literally going through frame by
Frame put on some music. Listen to a book or something
Another really interesting thing about this shot is that we actually filmed it practically. So it's a real lightsaber prop
We sliced an apple before hand put the Apple back together
And then tossed it at the lightsaber and I hit it out of the air like literally just like boom
and the apple just goes
Falling off to the right and it's not until it hits the ground when it finally like comes apart and then rolls to a stop
And that's when camera like whips down and we see it there. In fact, you can actually see the other half of the Apple
Kind of rolling away. It looks like I'm literally hitting a ball with the bat rather than cutting a ball with a lightsaber
so I had an idea I was like
how can we make this look like it's split so I literally just duplicated my footage and then as this going around
I literally just mess out just the Apple and it is it wasn't even a good mask
there's literally just a few points that feathered a bit and then I took that and I flipped it so I set the scale to
Negative 100%, only on the x-axis. I literally just flipped it
horizontally, shifted that Apple over and
I feather a little bit. look at that. We have a whole another Apple and this is what it looked like
Pwishh
hahah
All right, so get the lightsaber tracked in we got the Apple added so that there's some consistiancy to see with that
But now we have to have some sort of reaction because you know, you can't burn an apple without some smoke
Thats what grandpa always told me was you cant burn an apple without that smoke!!
Stock elements like sparks, little smoke, hits a little charge bursts,
You gotta add all that in
you gotta get your layers going
drop in some elements. I think I, what did I track here?
I think I tracked, like a thing on the ceiling. when you're tracking your footage
You always want to track the thing closest to where the element is gonna be placed
And the problem here is that the element is placed in the middle of the air
There's nothing around its that I can track. So I think I check the ceiling and that works fine. And then it looks good.
Pwishh
So that,
That little burst there is actually made of three different spark elements.
We got that one.
We got this one
and then the other one
Boom!
Thanks for watching this.
I know it wasn't really too much of a tutorial
but that's because this effect is dead simple to do
And you should go make your own lightsaber effects right now as well
so in the meantime
Let's go back and watch this William Tell experiment and see who can actually hit the Apple off of our heads
How has no one done this yet? I don't know it's hard
I dunno man
Having a person, down range.
[miss]
oooo
[hit]
Ohhh!!!
[apple quits]
Ohh!! Nooo!!
WOAHHH!!!!
im so dead son!
[????]
[montage]
Ohh!!
OH NO THAT WAS SO CLOSE!!
[more montage]
[noises]
I heard that!
Hey dude.
Oh I caught it!
[snickering]
Right in the back of the head!!
[Laughter]
Oh dude!
YOU KILLED ME NIKO!!!
I think that settles it
Adrian every time Adrian's been shooting he's been he's been going
vip!
He's been doing that
All right. Here we go Jake.
This is much worse. I wish i was facing-
[Dramatic music]
[Smack]
[slow-mo_Wren_Happy.jpeg]
HE GOT IT!!
YOU GOT IT
YOU'RE ALIVE!!
OHH MAN
IM ALIVE!!
You did. Good job!
Adrian did it!
I didn't, I didn't feel it, dude!
You sure look good, I look really good
It hit the Apple first. I didn't feel it. No, that is all apple dude, all apple. Yeah
We learned that William tail must have had a lot of boys
Congratulations Adrien like it's gotta regain my throne as archery champ, huh?
Losing a guy with a broken collarbone
If you can think of any historical challenges that we should try next
Let us know if you haven't subscribed, consider subscribing it you'll like it, we make good videos
[...]
[....]
[.....]
[......]
[gags]
We got a tutorial to do!
Oh yea!
Il'l eat you, later~
I was gonna use that for something and,
I totaly forgot what i was gonna use it for.
Uhmm
anyway